der film ist ein richtiges lehrstück man
lernt sehr viel über relativität über
schlaglöcher ich finde das echt super
gemacht also so ist der film in vieler
hinsicht sozusagen ihr wisst schon
voraus aber gleichzeitig auch hinterher
jede stunde die vestische planeten
verdrängt sind sieben jahre bei uns
schafft der erde würde das so aussehen
wie so eine reise wo ist ein kurs rat
tat für 23 minuten und dann ist man auf
der anderen seite dann ist man an einem
anderen ort im universum
endlich ist es wieder soweit wir machen
wieder wissenschaftler reagieren und
heute mit einer meiner lieblingsfilme
nämlich untersteller von christopher
nolan
ich habe euch gefragt was wir von diesem
film haltet und vor allem welche fragen
hier an die beiden wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler habt und ihr habt
uns unglaublich viele fragen gestellt
die ich gleich an die beiden stellen
werde
vorerst allerdings noch das hier ist
eine kooperation mit der max planck
gesellschaft genauso schon mit dem film
gattaca und ihr seht jetzt hier den
ersten teil auf meinem kanal und den
zweiten teil wo es dann um andere fragen
geht den seht ihr auf dem kanal der
max-planck-gesellschaft am ende dieses
videos hier werde ich euch das einfach
als abspann element verlinkt und da
könnt ihr nahtlos auf das zweite video
draufklicken jetzt aber erst mal zu
unseren beiden expertinnen und experten
gesprächen einmal mit doktor silke
briten vom max planck institut für
radioastronomie in bonn und mit doktor
franken vom max planck institut für
gravitationsphysik in hannover
hallo schön dass wir beiden da seid erst
mal vielen dank dass ihr euch die zeit
genommen hat und ich bin sehr gespannt
was sie zu untersteller zu sagen hat als
allererstes wer seid ihr und was macht
ihr wie sie sowieso könnt ihr euch so
gut mit schwarzen löchern aus wie ich
forscher haben als geldinstitut für
radio ist und ich bin teil der asko
kooperationen wir haben das erste foto
vom chancen nicht gemacht ich fand schon
lange sehr spannend und was mich auch
sehr stark interessiert ich bin auf der
suche nach verschlissenen schwarzen
büchern also supermassive schwarze
löcher die im doppelpack vorkommen und
die dann irgendwann verschmelzen werden
und hoffentlich dann mit lisa vielleicht
in zukunft in gravitationswellen
detektiert werden
danke frank ich arbeite max planck
institut für gravitationsphysik und wir
suchen und finden kann man
möglicherweise jetzt sagen
gravitationswellen das sind also kleines
der raumzeit störungen die mir großen
instrumenten aufgenommen werden
und die werden aus gesendet von
hauptsächlich verschmelzenden schwarzen
löchern und damit wir das aber finden
können und auch richtig interpretieren
was wird denn da so aufnehmen braucht es
leute die mich die also in
supercomputern simulieren wie sehen denn
die gravitationswellen aus die so zwei
schwarze löcher aussenden wenn jemand
kreisen wie verändern die sich wenn die
schwerer werdende leichter werden oder
oder schneller rotieren und das wird
dann alles zusammengepackt von der
simulation bis hin zur analyse von
solchen instrumenten und damit schauen
wieder tiefer ins universum
frank du kennst tatsächlich einen der
köpfe hinter diesen film den
wissenschaftler der ganz viel ganz viel
verantwortlich ist unter dem film kick
vorn
was hast du gedacht als den film gesehen
hast und wie für die wissenschaftler
akkurates zu dem film also dazu muss ich
sagen die erwartungshaltung war ziemlich
groß
wer wie er damit meine ich die
gravitationswellen physiker wir wussten
schon jahre voraus dass kid rock der mit
uns gemeinsam auf konferenzen geht und
so dass er also in hollywood arbeitet
wir alle ganz gespannt hatten so ein
bisschen blöd gehofft das
gravitationsfeld drin vorgaben okay dass
die kammer nicht drin vor direkt aber
also kleine enttäuschung gleich am
anfang aber der rest wird natürlich
großartig ok wunderbar ich bin sehr
gespannt auf den film dadurch sagen
starten wir direkt rein gucken uns den
film an an euch spoiler wir werden den
film komplett gucken und wir werden auch
das ende von films wollen darüber reden
also vielleicht erstmal noch mal den
film gucken wo wir jetzt dieses video
hier schaut und falls ihr den film
damals 2014 das letzte mal im kino
gesehen habe oder sowas dann könnte es
sich auch lohnen jetzt den film noch mal
vorher anzuschauen
einfach damit man die konzepte und
konkrete szenen die man setzen film
anschauen werden auch noch mal ganz
genau im kopf hat entdeckt haben wenn
ersten gravitations anomalien vor fast
50 jahren meist nur kleine die
informationen an instrumenten in der
hochatmosphäre aber von all diesen
anomalien
die signifikanteste in der nähe des
tatorts eine störung der raumzeit ist
das einfach noch aufgetaucht vor 48
jahren und es wird wohl in eine andere
galaxie ein wurmloch ist kein
natürliches phänomen
wir haben gerade gesehen wie über
gravitations anomalien gesprochen wurde
im film gibt es die an mehreren stellen
zum einen tauchen mehrere gravitations
anomalien im sonnensystem auf eine ist
ein wurmloch in der nähe des saturn
das erste was nicht gewundert hat das
gesagt wurde diese phänomene tauchen
nicht natürlich auf jetzt mal die erste
frage wo welcher gibt es die überhaupt
was ist das für ein konzept konnten wir
schon beobachten ein wohnlicher sind nie
beobachtet worden
wir haben keine gefunden in unseren
beobachtungen und aber ist sie zu hause
ist wenn nach einsteins gleichen der
jury verschiedene formen von bohrlöchern
möglich sind in das entsteht durch zwei
singularitäten die sich verbinden das
wohl noch wächst wird wieder kleiner und
spürt dann ab so das wäre ein wurmloch
wodurch man aber nicht reisen kann denn
alles was in dieser abschnürung gerät
wird zerstört also es ist meines
erachtens nach kein realistisches
szenario aber ist natürlich wenn man das
in so einem film einen worten
unglaublich elegante methode zu reisen
aber in der beobachtung haben bis heute
nicht gefunden es wäre schön wenn wir
auch so reißen könnten aber es könnte
sie theoretisch leben wo mancher oder
ich sehe es eher als eine theoretische
lösung von gleichungen aber nicht alle
theoretischen lösungen müssen auch in
der natur realisiert sein von daher bin
ich sehr skeptisch weiß nicht wie franke
sie ja genauso also das ist eine theorie
gibt es das schöne gleichung die das
irgendwie so suggerieren aber
gleichzeitig zu sagen wenn man aber alle
andere postulate der theorie befolgt
insbesondere man kann eben nicht
schneller reiten als nicht
geschwindigkeit dann dann geht das so
leider nicht
also wir müssen hier leider sagen
hollywood hat hier ein bisschen gelogen
und so toll der film auch immer für
seine wissenschaftliche korrektheit
gefeiert wird ist das dann eher im
science fiction bereich gelogen klingt
so klingt so böse aber ergebnis
natürlich in den bereich wo wir im
moment gar nicht wissen wie das
realisierbar sein soll
aber jetzt irgendwelche seltsame materie
hätte mit negativen energiedichten und
so weiter also völlig ausgeschlossen ist
das ja nie
deswegen gelogen finde ich zu hartum im
gipfelbereich wobei ich aber sehr
spekulativ die die theorie nutzt die
einem gerade für den hollywood plots ihm
helfen eine elegante spekulation
[Musik]
das war sie packte rein und sagen das
ist der erste handschlag zwischen den
beiden entitäten was ist das ist das
auch an die gravitation sunny woran
denkt ihr wenn ihr gravitations einmal
gehört ich denke zunächst mal an etwas
was und kapitulation zu tun hat was wir
aber nicht verstehen und sollte so etwas
aufbauen was wir nicht verstehen dann
ist es eigentlich das mit besseren
beobachtungen besseren theorien ist
verständlich wird eigentlich ist eine
anomalie eine unglaubliche chance für
die wissenschaft weil man lernt etwas
dazu und es geht weiter
wir kommen mit unserem verständnis der
weltweite ja ich meine gründe doch nur
das zentrum unserer unserer eigenen
galaxie beispielsweise schauen also man
sieht dort das resultat von von
gravitation also an so einen starken
anziehungskräften sieht das sterne um
irgendwas herum kreisen aber dort wo der
umgang ist halt nicht sagt man wird als
das ist kein leuchtender ganz so wie
sich großer stern oder so und klar dass
es keine anomalien sind dass wir nicht
verstehen was das ist wir wissen dass
supermassives schwarzes loch im zentrum
unserer eigenen galaxie ist aber das
sind eben solche sachen sind die effekte
von gravitation die ursache wo das nun
genau herkommt es nicht immer sofort
klar
angeblich wollte er kippt noch also eine
produzenten dass da also
gravitationswellen drin vorkommen dass
ursprünglich sollte wohl die geschichte
auch so sein dass man also koalitions
willen detektiert hat aber dann sagte
wohl christopher nolan ist das ist zu
kompliziert wir müssen wir zu erklären
aus den koalitionsreihen
die gemessen also sagen wir einfach
aktions anomalien und wenige jahre ein
zwei jahre nachdem der film rauskam
wurde tatsächlich gravitationswellen zum
ersten mal gemessen und angeblich hat
also küste von holländern kippbaren
angerufen und gesagt tut mir leid das
alles damals rausgeschnitten haben jetzt
jetzt würden dass die leute natürlich
spiel klare einordnen können was das ist
ja da war sozusagen der film wir ganz
kleines bisschen zurück kam heraus
man hätte noch ein paar jahre warten
können dann hätte
das erste bild des schaffens des
schwarzen lochs gehört absolut
naja stimmt also so ist der film in
vieler hinsicht so zu sagen würde wir
wissen schon voraus aber gleichzeitig
auch feier hing hinter hinterher
die ersten gravitations anomalien haben
alles verändert plötzlich wussten wir
dass wir schwerkraft nutzbar machen
können
da hab ich auch darüber nachgedacht was
das bedeuten soll also dass wir jetzt
gravitation nutzen einerseits muss
natürlich sagen nutzen wir gerade dazu
ja sowieso schon ständig auf der erde
sowie zwei wasserkraftwerken oder so
wenn man irgendwas nach unten schickt
dann arbeitet ja die gravitationskraft
für mich und ich kann der energie
herausgegeben andererseits ist immer die
frage kann ich gravitation für noch mehr
nutzen viel aktiver ich habe einmal
vortrag gehört jemand spekulierte dass
eine höher entwickelte zivilisation dass
man die fladen erkennt dass die
gravitationswellen sender irgendwo
platziert und wir das aufnehmen und
nicht radiowellen irgendwas das ist
natürlich auch alles spekulation aber
das sind so die zwei gebiete an dich
denken musste als es hieß hannes in
gravity also einerseits kavitation die
das kann natürlich nutzen
potentielle energie daraus wurden solche
geschichten andererseits im prinzip als
kommunikationsmedium
gleichwohl muss man sagen um jetzt sogar
schärfte er der gravitationswellen zu
erzeugen die irgendwo messbar sind echte
man energien die unvorstellbaren groß
sind also da müsste ich quasi ganze
sonne nehmen und den belgier und will
nun etwas tolles dann da ginge das
vielleicht aber sonst ist das eine sehr
weite zukunft
wir fahren mal sitzen jedes jahr heeren
der regen ausbleibt und wir sagen wer
ist das ja aber das nächste jahr rettet
uns nicht genauso wenig wie dass danach
die welt ist schön donald aber sie sagt
uns schon lange müssen sie verlassen
dem entscheid wird auf der erde geboren
sein muss aber nicht hier sterben die
menschheit wurde auf der erde geboren
sie muss aber nicht hier sterben das
finde ich ein super spannenden satz es
gibt ja eine ganz große debatte zwischen
wir sollten auf jeden fall den mars
kriminalisieren und wir sollten
versuchen aus unserem sonnensystem
rauszukommen wir müssen ich mir das
überleben sichern
und wenn man auf zwei planeten ist sind
wir sicher das ist quasi das backup auf
der anderen seite haben wir hier auf der
erde jetzt gerade probleme und es gibt
so viele menschen denen es nicht gut
geht und unser planet stirbt gerade was
kann man dazu sagen wie steht die
wissenschaftler dazu oder zumindest ihr
beiden persönlich ist ich denke wir
sollten nicht einen planeten nach dem
anderen folien also ich glaube wir
sollten erstmal versuchen die probleme
auf diesem planeten zu lösen
andererseits denke ich die weltraum
ökonomie hat längst begonnen
also es wird geplant irgendwelche hotels
im weltraum weltraumreisen 3d drucker
die im weltraum drucken sollen
das heißt nicht dass die menschheit als
solche reisen muss oder oder als kolonie
irgendwo angesiedelt werden muss aber
den nutzen den nutzen des weltraums ich
glaube das wird bereits begonnen
wir sind wir mittendrin ja also ich als
kind mit auf große star trek finden und
war das überfällig faszinierend zu
anderen welten zu weisen
jetzt wo ich das beruflich mache mir die
zahlen anschaut ist das doch ein
bisschen ernüchtert muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen aber sie einfach vor augen
führt wie riesig das universum ist und
wie klein wir sind und auch wie langsam
man reisen kann
also ist es dauert ja schon jahre um nur
zu einem anderen planeten unserem
eigenen sonnensystem zu reisen und so
besonders freundlich dass man jetzt
unbedingt roßleben bilden sind jetzt
alle nicht im moment die persönlichkeit
ist absolut utopisch zu glauben dass die
menschliche zivilisation tatsächlich
irgendwann mal die erde verlassen wird
und auf einen anderen planeten reisen
wird einfach weil die größenordnung sind
einfach unvorstellbar die steuerung ist
die gleich mit der serie begründet wir
sollten doch sehr vorsichtig mit unserem
planeten thema haben umgehen und dankbar
sein für das was haben mit unverständnis
registers davon weil sich zum zu alpha
centauri oder sowas zu reisen aber zum
beispiel zum mars ist ja nicht utopisch
die das stimmt genau aber da hört die
liste schon fast auf nicht klar zum zum
mars reisen zu venus vielleicht aber das
sind die beiden optionen attraktiv
spielt kein biologe aber ich bin
die biologen würden uns ziemlich schnell
erklären warum das ist auch da und
energie bräuchte doch das für menschen
lebbar und ich will gar nicht angenehm
sagen zu machen genau also deswegen so
toll optionen haben wir unserem eigenen
sonnensystem nicht aber über unser
eigenes sonnensystem hinaus reisen ist
einfach unrealistisch nachdem beide nach
dem heutigen stand der technik
natürlich wird es nicht von heute auf
morgen passieren auf dem mars reisen
aber vor allem immer wenn über space
travel und diese kosten dahinter
gesprochen wird
und sage ich auch ganz gerne wie viel
uns dass gebracht hat also zum beispiel
die iss und wie viele innovationen
dadurch gekommen sind und auch welche
die tatsächlich unserem planeten helfen
also zum beispiel können wir durch
satelliten inzwischen waldbrände
vorhersagen und schrecken und viel
besser wissen wir wie unser klima
funktioniert das funktioniert alles nur
durch space travel also es bedingt sich
natürlich auch ein bisschen gegenseitig
und ich sage immer ja natürlich haben
wir auf der erde wichtigere probleme und
die haben diesen tief vorrang
aber man kann beides machen ja das würde
ich 100 prozent überschreiten also die
man darf nicht die grundlagenforschung
wie einstampfen nur wenn man sagt ja da
können jetzt im nächsten 50 jahren sehen
wir jetzt keinen unmittelbaren nutzen
für die medizin aus oder so so
funktioniert das natürlich nicht es gibt
es wir müssen uns als menschheit
weiterentwickeln und ein zur größten
faszinierendsten rätsel ist nur das
universum also der sonne so muss es
endlich weitergehen
auf der iss sind schon jetzt
interessante experimente die der medizin
helfen werden
statt also von daher läuft das ja und
das sieht richtig super spannendes okay
gut aber dann ins zimmer
das ist eine kugel ja natürlich was
dachtest du es werden lacht nein es ist
ne alle illustration die ich gesehen
habe da illustration soll nur das
prinzip veranschaulichen
sagen wir mal du willst von hier nach
dort aber das ist zu weit okay also für
ein wurmloch wird die raumzeit gekrümmt
und man nimmt eine abkürzung durch eine
höhere dimension
ok also deutlich wird das wenn man
dreidimensionalen raum zweidimensional
darstellt dann ist das wurmloch nämlich
nur noch
ein kreis und was ist ein kreis in drei
dimensionen eine kugel ganz genau
ein kugelförmiges lag aber könntest du
dich wirklich ja frank also wenn direkt
starten willst mach das gerne ich wollte
das unbedingt darüber sprechen weil das
ja diese standards erklärung von diesem
gefaltetem papier und ich hatte schon
immer mal interessiert ob der
wissenschaftler denken so aber nicht
schon wieder oder ob das tatsächlich
eine elegante lösung ist das zu erklären
weil das ist richtig also erstmal freue
ich mich darüber dass die stadt jetzt
wurden noch als als kugel darstellen es
ist schon wahr wenn man sich denkt dass
das irgendwie konstruiert wurde oder
auch aus dem kollaps von irgendwas
entsteht würde das immer sphärisch
aussehen also das ist das ist schon mal
besser ist schon mal sehr schön dann
natürlich krimi ist immer ein
schwieriges thema wenn wir von des
gekrümmten vorstellen da denken wir
immer eine nieder dimensional dann zum
beispiel zweidimensionale fläche ein
stück papier und sohn gewarnt
wenn ich das jetzt krümmer dann kann ich
die krümmung sehen weil wir sind in den
dreidimensionalen raum jetzt oder nur
zweidimensional und so macht die
erklärung im prinzip auch sinn ja dann
nimmt ja auch ein stück papier und sagte
jetzt irgendwas gekrümmt also nämlich
was zweidimensionales krümmel sind all
die menschen dazu muss man aber sagen
dass braucht man eigentlich gar nicht
also wohl sicher kann man durchaus
wunderbare schreiben ohne dass mir jetzt
höhere dimension braucht aber das ist
einfach ich sag mal böse unser gehirn
ist dafür nicht gemacht deswegen finde
ich das völlig verständlich dass es auch
in dem film so erklärt wird weil das ein
gutes bild gibt aber eben kein
vollständiges ich fand es gar nicht so
schlecht dargestellt ehrlich gesagt es
hat die krümmung es hat dieses
durchgehend von der einen seite aus die
anderen seite und es hat diesen aspekt
der abbildung in einem zweidimensionalen
bereich dann ich finde auch gut wie
schon wieder erklärt hat mit dem apfel
und dem wurm der durchwandert so geht es
auch kommt daher die ursprüngliche
bezeichnung wohl noch john wheeler den
begriff geprägt die ameise oder was auch
immer kann sich auf der einen seite um
den apfel raum bewegen das wäre der
längere weg aber es gibt eine abkürzung
durch das wurmloch und das ist halt
äquivalent zu der beschreibung mit dem
gekrümmten papier wo man auch die
möglichkeit landes papiers zu wandern
oder durch die zwei löcher die abkürzung
zu nehmen und daher kam das was viele
leute anderen loch denke nämlich so wie
bei einem schwarzen loch was ja auch
eine kugel ist wo jetzt der film direkt
versucht hat zu erklären was das ganze
wirklich ist und für den zuschauer ist
das vielleicht sogar richtig gut weil
der zuschauer muss ich dann nicht wenn
ich blöd vorkommen sondern der denker
auf jede kugel fand faszinieren der film
ist ein richtiges lehrstück man lernt
sehr viel über relativität über schwarze
löcher wurden löcher in das glas reisen
diese ganzen effekte ich finde das echt
super gebracht zu den bogen noch fällt
natürlich ein das bild das auch total
toll aber sieht ja darauf solche solche
rand effekte also irgendwie wird das
licht der umgebogen schon da sagt
natürlich wieder der zahlen besessene
wieder in mir also dass schon durch
lichteffekte hat dann muss er so viele
gravitation haben dass das ganze
sonnensystem irgendwie durcheinander
gewirbelt wird also schon spannend dass
da irgendwas relativ große sitzen kann
als wohl auch aber gleichzeitig scheint
das ja nur so mit kleinen anomalien
entdeckt raum zu sein und mich glücklich
den daten völlig aus der bahn wird
müsste ich mich das erklären soll aber
das ist natürlich die freiheit die ich
von hier mitnehmen darf ich glaube dass
wurde realistisch gerechnet wie ihr
welche größen sondern wohnen doch haben
sollte mit der öffnung mit der länge und
dann wurde auch darauf geachtet von
gibson soweit ich weiß dass die sterne
nicht größe deformiert sein sollten also
die linsen effekte sollten den zuschauer
jetzt nicht ablenken und sollten auch
nicht mit den größten teleskopen auf der
welt beobachtbar sein also es war schon
alles richtig durchgerechnet
aber ich glaube es gab dann nicht die
effekte im film also es sah nicht gut
genug aus und das danach justiert wurde
[Musik]
die steuerung funktioniert hier nicht
passieren denn bald das licht raum
jenseits unserer
die missionen wir können nur auf
zeichnen und beobachten
ist das realistisch also ich würde das
so aussehen wie so eine reise wo es dann
kurz grad für 23 minuten und dann ist
man auf der anderen seite dann ist man
an einem anderen ort im universum also
wie gesagt es gibt es nicht von daher
ist da den usa sehr viele künstlerische
freiheiten zugestanden
aber es beruht wie gesagt auf
realistischen rechnung was mich an
diesen stellen geärgert hat ist es
dieses randes des raumschiffs also ich
fand das irgendwie so ein bisschen der
uns ein bisschen zu simpel da hätte ich
gedacht dass ich vielleicht noch ein
bisschen mehr antreten ja ich hab mir
wert sind jetzt auch die tipps geholt
genauso der macht dann auch der
wissenschaftler wird dann bei mir auf
und nur noch der der hollywood es
aussehen soll wenn man durch irgendetwas
gibt was es ja eigentlich nicht gibt ist
frei die mit schwierig beantworten kann
klar man kann sich fragen ob nicht die
gezeitenkräfte das irgendwann zerreißen
würden das raumschiff aber also wer
wirklich so offensichtlich gibt es auch
welche die aber auch nicht gerade so
stark dass also der einzige effekt ist
dass die elektronik in china
funktioniert so gut dass das mittel hin
als dramatisches element ok also da
würde dann eher sagen dass es jetzt der
der hollywood bullshit kraft das alles
müssen übertrieben dass du jetzt gesagt
ja jetzt generell mal zu dieser frage
kommunikation durch wurmlöcher ich weiß
jetzt schon sehr viel zu wohl mancher
gefragt und die antwort das immer es
gibt es eigentlich nicht nur rein
theoretisch
trotzdem könnte man durch wurmlöcher
auch informationen senden ja also in dem
szenario wenn es möglich wäre also es
gibt sie nicht aber wenn es doch gäbe
und man hätte irgendein exotische
materie oder negative energie
unrühmliche langem aufzutreten dass ich
was durch bewegen könnte dann müsste es
klappen spekulativ ich habe auch meine
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer gefragt was
sie gerne von euch wissen wollen würden
und ein zuschauer hat gefragt ob es dann
wichtig für ein wurmloch wäre wie weit
die entfernung zwischen zwei punkten im
universum ist wenn es das denn gäbe also
würde ein wurmloch anders aussehen wenn
es quasi nur einen kleinen kleinen
bereich bewegen würde oder wenn es halt
zum anderen ende des universums geben
würde
da kann man wirklich nicht erklären denn
je nachdem wie es gemacht wurde klar
wenn der raum einfach gekrümmt wird
zwischen zwei enden die eigentlich ganz
weit entfernt liegen aber der wird der
raum jetzt irgendwie dazwischen gekrümmt
dann ist ja trotzdem selbst wenn ich den
krimmer wenn die zwei enden wollte von
dem fernsehen dauert auch länger dadurch
zu reisen würde ich auch so erwarten
andererseits wenn ich schon einige
freiheit haben kann ich natürlich
einfach zwei teile des raumes
zusammenpacken und dann jemand durch
gewissen das wäre ins land
aber das wäre glaube ich noch noch einen
schritt spekulation mehr
jetzt geht es um das schwarze loch der
planet ist viel näher an garanto als wir
dachten die agentur so nennen wir das
schwarze loch die planeten von müller
und sackten um chryslers ist ist ein
horizont wie ein basketball auf dem ring
eine landung bringt uns gefährlich nah
ran und die anziehungskraft beim
schwarzen noch dieser größe ist gewaltig
also ich könnte diesen neutronenstern
umfliegen um abzubremsen
die zeit ist das problem verglichen mit
der erde verlangsamt die gravitation auf
dem planeten unsere zeit extrem und wie
sehr jede stunde die wir auf diesem
planeten verbringen sind sieben jahre
bei uns auf der erde
das ist relativität freunde
zu sagen dass eingeschwebt 130%
irritationen kommt kommt hier ist nichts
was müsste genau hier sein
[Musik]
neben dem floß
ok also die crew ist inzwischen durch
das wohl noch getrennt und wir sind
beide agentur den großen schwarzen loch
um das zwei planeten rumfliegen und zwar
einmal der von müller und einmal der von
dr brand und der von müller um den geht
es jetzt das ist der wasser planet ganz
ganz beliebtes gesprächsthema wenn es um
wintersteller geht denn der ist so knapp
am ereignishorizont vom schwarzen loch
das die gravitation die zeit so stark
rühmt das eine stunde auf diesem
planeten sieben jahre in der echten welt
oder zu hause auf der erde bedeuten
erstmal was haltet ihr von diesem
konzept und ist das realistisch oder
stimmt das das ist realistisch ist so
gerechnet worden
von chip soc mit den vorgaben genau so
also eine stunde entspricht sieben
jahren auf der erde also der planet ist
so nah am schwarzen noch der
nächstmögliche orbit ohne dass der
planet zerrissen wird
und dann kommt noch ein weiterer punkt
hinzu das schwarze loch muss sich sehr
schnell drehen mussten sehr hohen
spinnen haben damit diese zeitgleichen
quasi funktioniert und ich glaube das
sind 0 5 998 vom maximalen spin
das ist prinzipiell möglich aber nicht
wahrscheinlich also aber macht er ist
das und das finde ich so spannend dass
das stimmt das wirklich fassen also da
kann sich ja der film tatsächlich dann
sagen könnte er theoretisch
funktionieren also diese mussten da auf
dem auf dem planeten zu sein und dass
matthew mcconaughey also cooper verpasst
wie seine tochter groß wird ist ja ein
storytelling mechanismus der genial ist
ja und ich meine der zuschauer fiebert
quasi mit und schaut auf die uhr
wie lange sind sie jetzt haben was
bedeutet dass und man für den westlichen
auge läuft ab wie das leben auf dem auf
der erde weitergeht ich finde das
unglaublich gut gemacht und im
hintergrund hört man die musik von hans
zimmer wo dann die uhr auch noch mit
drin ist nur kritik
also ist das ist wirklich eine meiner
lieblingsszenen vom ganzen film
frank du hast wenn ich nicht recht den
sinn sogar ein bisschen kalkuliert
richtig war ich ein bisschen skeptisch
wie viel zeit unterschiede die zeit die
situation denn wir das ja sowie wie
unterschiedlich die uhren laufen können
ob das so möglich ist daher nicht das
einfachste schwarze loch was es gibt mir
vorstellen dass gar nicht rotiert dann
ist es so klar bin ich beliebig nah am
eiger nordwand geht auch die zeit
beliebig
langsam wirklich der erde aber dort gibt
es keine stabilen orbitz mehr
wenn ich also auch den auf dem stabilen
orbit bin der am nächsten an einem nicht
rotierenden schwarzen doch dran ist wie
viel wie viel langsamer geht da die zeit
und da tatsächlich der faktor nur etwa
40 prozent oder sowas
also dann könnte man niemals solche
riesigen zeitunterschiede wie dort
beschrieben rauskriegen aber hat ja gibt
ordnung sein buch aufgeschrieben wenn
man in rotierendes schwarzes loch hat
dann geht das tatsächlich darf man den
effekt dass also die orbits können näher
an den eigenen horizont ereignisse sind
selber schuld auch ein bisschen und
alles was nah genug dran ist muss auch
quasi mit tieren ja und damit bewegt
sich also die orbits noch mal extra
schnell drum herum und da kriegt man
wirklich was schon beliebig große
zeitunterschiede hin wie eben auch
dieses eine stunde sind sind sieben
jahre aber da braucht man schon elegant
ganz speziellen platz im universum
aber im prinzip könnte es hier geben auf
dem planeten ist er relativ hell und
aber der der planet von dr müller
arbeitet ja um ein schwarzes loch herum
würde es nicht eigentlich total dunkel
sein
das ganze hat eine akkretionsscheibe und
die akkretionsscheibe ist wo sich
material gesammelt und durch reibung
prozesse verschiedene andere prozesse
aufgeheizt wird das heißt wenn man so
ein typisches supermassives schwarzes
loch was jetzt wesentlich massiver wäre
als in dem film das hat 100 millionen
grad
also das ist richtig heiß und strahlt
dann auch im brandbereich im gange
bereich hat einen jet hat magnetfelder
all das ist hier weggelassen also um
nicht die aller verwurzeln zu lassen hat
es eine deutlich geringere temperatur in
dieser akkretionsscheibe die das
magnetfeld gibt es nicht mehr wenn ich
jetzt auch nicht also von daher ist es
schon hell und unterm arm
von daher funktioniert das dann manchmal
zwei fragen zur gravitation auf diesem
wasser planeten zum einen sank die eine
schauspielerin
es ist total schwierig sich zu bewegen
also die gravitation ist da wohl stärker
die gravitation die sie spüren vom
planeten also wie sehr sie an den
planeten herangezogen werden ist ja
nicht die des schwarzen lochs und die
für die zeit delegation sorgt oder
also es ist ja die zeit situation kommt
von der gravitation des schwarzen loch
ist aber die erdanziehung oder wie stark
ich einen planeten angezogen werde und
sagt das 130 erdanziehung die kommt
natürlich von der gravitationskraft des
planeten
der könnte natürlich größer kleiner wie
auch immer sein also wenn er die gleiche
größe hat sagen wir wie die erde und
aber 30 prozent mehr masse dann wäre das
schon für dich wirklich nachvollziehbar
dass das 100 130 prozent der
gravitationskraft tritt ich glaube mein
gefühl ist einmal der film tut so als
wäre weil wir nach dem schwarzen loch
dran sind auf einmal der planet und die
kraft der die anziehungskraft schwerer
das stimmt natürlich genau okay gut
während jungs kraft ist wirklich nur der
eigenschaft ist planeten oder gar nichts
mit den kosten zu tun was aber
vermutlich was mit der fraktion noch zu
tun hat sie sind ja glaub ich die
riesigen wellen ja die haben was in
schwarzem wird zu tun
der planet schaukelt aufgrund
gezeitenkräfte und dadurch sparten die
ozeane hoch und das ist glaube ich pro
stunde kommt so eine welle und das haut
auch hin mit den vorstellungen der
regierung nahe dran ist und die
gravitationskraft zu so groß ist das
heißt das ist tatsächlich realistisch
das heißt dass es wissenschaftlich okay
wenn das so die gezeitenwelle ist dann
wird er quasi auf den beiden also der
seite vom planet dem schaut sie noch
zugewartet wird quasi das wasser ein
bisschen mehr angezogen auf der anderen
seite gibt es in der gegen gesetzt
direkt genau die bei uns auf der erde
mit dem mond und weise der planet würde
sich darunter so wegdrehen
das war ganz wurscht er die welle steht
dreht sich so klar hat der hollywood
wieder ein ort gefunden der das
besonders dramatisch macht also ich
frage mich warum ist das wasser so flach
dort und auch besteigt das so rapide an
es sieht ein bisschen aus wie dem
tsunami also da hat man schon
verschiedene konzepte miteinander
gemischt aber das heißt nicht dass man
wenn wir nicht alles ganz genau
freundlich und könnte jetzt durchaus
schon in solchen extrem ordners
universums auf solche extremfälle sehr
cool
also ich bin echt immer wieder
beeindruckt von intercell und wie
akkurat das ganze dann ist ich habe noch
eine user frage und zwar von christoph
gößl
im film wird es so dargestellt als würde
der einfluss von kantor auf die zeit der
laktation erst ab einem bestimmten
entfernung slammed existieren
ist das wirklich so da steigt der
einfluss eigentlich graduell an der
strecke eigentlich graduell an und
quasi am rand das des schwarzen lochs da
hat man dann wirklich dem punkt wo die
zeit stillzustehen scheint also wenn man
jemanden sehen würde dass ich dort
hinein bewegt dann würde das bild
eingefroren am ereignishorizont aber für
diejenigen denn der dadurch fällt für
den läuft es natürlich weiter aber die
zeit geht dann richtung singularität
also nur in richtung eben schwarzen
sachen richtige singularität und es
kommt nichts mehr nach außen da kommen
wir jetzt sehr genau zu dem wirklich
wirklich spannenden zum eigentlichen
schwarzen loch und was passiert wenn man
in ein schwarzes loch hinein fällt das
kommt jetzt leicht im zweiten teil auf
dem kanal der max-planck-gesellschaft
vielen dank euch schonmal hierfür und
wir sehen dass jetzt gleich direkt wenn
ich hier klickt im zweiten teil wieder
und ich habe gerne meine kommentare wie
ihr intercell landet und was ihr davon
haltet und klickt gerne hier um es den
zweiten teil zu sehen
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten mal